yes it is true that the capitalist
system is breaking down due to the
incentives built into it and a failure
to properly regulate nearly any level of
it whatsoever and to allow companies to
get too big wield too much power and not
be able to do anything about it at this
point and lacking both the political
will or appetite to do so from anyone
who holds any position of supposed power
but um all that might be
true have you considered upgrading to
capitalism
Plus
[Music]
so in one of my videos last month I went
off a little bit on uh on a few things
and kind of threatened to talk about
some of the larger aspects of
how so much of what's going on is
falling apart uh and by Design like the
short version is uh we're paying for
more we're getting less and yet also a
lot of these companies technically
aren't still profitable yet somehow also
are so uh I've got a lot to go over I'm
not going to say that this is going to
be necessarily a magnum opus on
capitalism but I'm going to touch on a
fair few things while trying to focus
primarily on the ideas of goods and
services being worse and costing more
and yes there is a term that is a fairly
recently coined one for this that I will
bring up I'm not going to say it early
in the video though because YouTube gets
weird about uh cursing early on and
there is a swear built into the phrase
but we'll get
there in any case I don't know how long
I'm going to go on but we got a lot to
talk about as I said the general notion
of we're paying more and getting less
has been on a lot of people's minds I
think one of the easiest ways to kind of
quantify that cuz like it's happening
almost across the board but one of the
easiest ways to quantify that is what's
going on with streaming right now
multiple streaming services are not only
just cancelling shows they are purging
them from their system they're no longer
available to stream and they are also at
the same time jacking up their prices
now Max I think it was still HBO Max at
the time now it's just max I don't know
at what point lost track of the timeline
it's all a mess it's been broken the
whole time so it doesn't really matter
at what point it happened uh whether it
lined up with the renaming or not but
with Max that was kind of kicked
everything off where they purged shows
like infinti train and did not release
the Batgirl movie and got rid of a whole
bunch of stuff on the
platform and then proceeded to jack up
the price even before they jacked up the
price the question was being asked so
we're paying the same amount of money
for literally less stuff there's less
stuff here now and you're charging us
the same and then they up the price and
of course most of the other streamers
have since followed suit Disney's
another one that has done a fair bit of
that purging shows from in some cases
only a few months after they've been put
up and now also upping their pricing
you've had Netflix that has cracked down
on password sharing has introduced these
other tiers and is also looking into
upping its price if they have haven't
done it already again I'm losing track
of all these things so it's all costing
more a lot of it literally has less
stuff so this whole thing which uh has
the recently coined term of andhi
ification because it was an okay thing
and it's been deliberately made worse
the thing
is most of the time this happens it's
not an
accident well actually technically it's
never an accident in that this is a
choice being made by the corporations
and the people who run them now in some
cases it may not have been a choice that
they had set out to make but in other
cases it's been built in and it's been
their intention from the start of
business in some cases it came about
more or less organically or even in a
couple instances possibly even
accidentally in so far as they kind of
stumbled into it and then
did and then started doing it on purpose
I'll kind of go over all this but before
we get into this by and large this term
which was initially coined by Cory drro
uh has largely been used to describ
digital Goods streaming services video
games things with subscription fees you
know those kinds of things that's the
main thing it's kind of been used or at
least that was what it initially was
used to describe you know you're paying
a subscription for a thing then it gets
overhauled and it's worse and they're
charging charging you the same oh no
wait now they're charging you more what
the actual
hell let's first recognize that this is
a natural um sort of I want to say
Evolution I'm going to go with mutation
this is a natural occurring mutation and
extrapolation out from something that
has been
around basically since uh after the
Industrial
Revolution planned obsolescence now I
could do an entire l video just
explaining planned obsolescence and
going over specific instances of it
rather than doing that if you want a
full breakdown I will direct you to that
video made by some more news but here's
the quick breakdown planned
obsolescence basically is the embodiment
of the phrase they don't make them like
they used to you've heard that right
well it's true they don't make them like
they used to deliberately by choice
because the way things used to be
pre-industrial revolution let's say you
were a woodworker in a village you made
a chair and you made a real good chair
and Not only would it survive the life
of the person who bought it they could
probably keep it in their house and then
their children would have it maybe even
their grandchildren and that's fine
because your needs aren't that great
there's enough people in the village you
make a chair you make a table you'll be
fine so the old idea of making things to
last because that's why they come to you
to get you to make a chair as opposed to
the other guy in town who can make a
chair but it's going to break in 10
years no you get the good thing the
thing that'll last well that doesn't
really work once you start to scale
things up past the needs of one
individual crafts person once you start
scaling up to Industrial levels and once
you make uh transportation in such a way
that you can now move your product out
to vastly more people initially you're
going to be raking it in you're going to
sell them this thing sell all it to all
the people in this town you're now a
chair magnate all these people in town
get a chair that lasts a lifetime then
the state then the country then everyone
in the world gets a chair that lasts a
lifetime and then what do you
do nobody has to replace the chair
doesn't break so you'll have this growth
as you spread out to everyone you can
sell it to and like realistically you
can't sell it to everyone on the planet
but you you hit the addressable market
and at a certain point your growth
slows because there aren't that many
people left who haven't bought it and
the people who've already bought it they
don't need a new one once you scale up
industry to be able to hit that big and
addressable Market this is a problem now
there's a couple of ways to address it
one is to basically make different
products as well but that's just kind of
Kick the Can down the road you did
chairs now you do tables now you do
dining room sets now you do beds okay
but you're still going to hit the same
problem
eventually so what do we do about this
well in more recent times you add a lot
of digital bells and whistles but at a
more basic level and this goes back as I
say decades and decades um you don't
make it to last as
long you don't want it to last forever
you want it to break you want it to need
to be replaced because that way you
don't sell it to somebody once you sell
it over and over again as they need to
replace the old
one this is something that we can
actually track through a single
corporate mascot you ever hear the May
tag man the mayag man was a campaign for
mayag which made various electronic
utilities washers dryers later on
expanding into dishwashers microwaves
refrigerators Etc and the main tag man
the whole pitch with that ad campaign
when it started back in the 60s was the
May tag man's the loneliest guy in town
because almost nobody ever calls him
it's not often that anybody needs us may
tag
repairman that's why we're the loneliest
guys in town May tags are so wellb built
they don't even need to be serviced
hardly at all poor guy there is one
difference between Newton and
mayag Newton needs me now interestingly
last decade they brought back the May
tag man also revamped him so now it was
like a kind of a funny cute visual thing
where like he was embodying the utility
or the appliance it was It was kind of
cute but you'll notice they're not doing
the same thing anymore because the
products aren't made to last anymore and
they know that so they brought back the
character from The Nostalgia but they
had to do a completely different thing
with him because these things aren't
made like that anymore it's arguable how
much they were actually made
in the vein of what they claimed they
were but they can't even claim that now
and they know it I remember when I was
younger you'd go to a place like Sears
and you'd see stuff with stickers on it
that would say lifetime
guarantee you don't see that anymore if
you're lucky you'll see something with a
10-year guarantee more likely a five
they don't even bother trying to pretend
that it'll last longer than that and
that's not even getting into the issue
that a lot of these lifetime guarantees
are warranties that have a lot of
loopholes in them so it was still
perfectly capable of breaking down just
in a way that they weren't going to be
willing to replace because they were it
in legales but even setting that
aside good luck finding anything with a
lifetime guarantee
anymore so that was planned
obsolescence and that
mentality leads very
naturally into inchid ification so let's
talk a bit more about that as I said
the streaming services are a really good
example but pretty much anything that
starts out as honestly this is just
amazing but there's either going to be
something going on behind the scenes or
they're going to have to implement
something later that's going to make it
all go to hell here's a fun fact I bet a
lot of you either don't know or have
forgotten when Hulu the streaming
service that Disney just fully bought
out 100% corporate consolidation it's a
nightmare but uh Hulu when it first
launched it was free Hulu beams TV
directly to your portable Computing
devices giving you more of the cerebral
gelatinizing shows you want anytime
anywhere for free that was the
pitch it didn't stay free and they were
never ever going to keep it free but it
launched as free we built Hulu the pump
thousands of hours of free TV right into
the one screen you drag around
everywhere because that is how they
hooked people in they got people
invested in the product and then they
started offering Hulu Plus and our
latest Silver Bullet Hulu Plus full
seasons and full series runs of your
favorite shows in your new favorite
place everywhere oh yeah we still got
free Hulu but here's the thing with
extra
stuff and then you keep expanding get as
many people who are on the free version
to start paying for it and then you just
start jacking up the price that was
always the plan it had to be the initial
business model of it's
free was unsustainable actually this is
part of what got me on this in the first
place streaming models are unsustainable
for the most part as is the only one
that has been posting any profit at all
is Netflix and even they aren't in the
clear because they have billions of
dollars in debt
but they are technically year-over-year
making profit at least currently
but part of this whole thing and part of
what lights the fire under it is it's
not enough to be profitable you have to
be growing but I will come back to that
stick a pin in it we'll come back to it
you know what's a good industry to look
at as sort of an embodiment of this
video games again I have the benefit of
age when I was a kid video games did
actually still cost 60 bucks brand new
for the most part and it was a complete
experience whether it was a good
experience or bad experience depending
on the game you got but it was a
complete experience whatever the game
could do it was all there on the
cartridge yeah that's how old I am NES
NS NES baby cartridges all the way but
it was either there on the cartridge or
it wasn't when you bought it you got it
whatever was there was yours so let's
take a look at a specific series let's
take a look at I don't know Mortal
Kombat so Mortal Kombat starts out and
back in the 16bit days you would have
fun stuff like unlockable characters
alternate costumes that were just
already on the C maybe you had to unlock
them through gameplay or with a code but
they were all there you had all of it
when you bought it Flash Forward a few
years and suddenly we get DLC and
microtransactions then later on down the
line what if we didn't sell complete
alternate costumes what if we sold
Cosmetics what if we sold a ton of
variants of I don't know just a vest
just a belt just the
boots and all of that was available for
sale as individual pieces hey I put them
in a loop box sure but like we sell it
we sell it in
pieces this stuff used to just be
included it was just part of the product
now an example like Mortal Kombat is
kind of what I mean when I say some uh
aspects of incen ification are companies
kind of stumbling ass backwards into it
and I think something like that is kind
of the case I think it started with when
microtransactions first became a thing
and horse armor was a joke it was a meme
everybody laughed at it but as it became
normalized the idea of
microtransactions I think companies like
nether realm which makes um
which makes the Mortal Kombat games I
think they probably looked at well do
you think we would they go for this
let's try it and I I don't think
especially for you know a game series
and a company that's been around since
the early
90s they didn't go in in the 9s going
and in in 30 years we'll be selling them
individual cosmetic pieces so while some
of the companies we're going to be
talking about later and some some of the
ones I've already mentioned uh such as
Hulu were deliberately always intending
to alter their structure and their
pricing and what they offered that
wasn't the case with something like
Mortal Kombat but they still end up in
the same end place you're either paying
more to get the same thing or you're
paying the same amount and getting less
because I've picked on Mortal Kombat
because it's an easy one to sort of
gauge over time but most video games at
this point if if it is a what is
generally called AAA game these are the
big budget fully rendered fully 3D
realistic Graphics kind of games by the
major Studios with names you recognize
Nintendo Sony uh Sega EA Activision
Blizzard and etc etc those sorts of
folks pretty much all of those at this
point the $60 price is a starter price
that's what you pay for the base game
but it will will be missing tons of
stuff that 30 years ago if it existed
for the game at all would have just been
included and now it's not now I'm sure
there are some people out there uh
Defenders of video games who will make
an argument like well no no no no no no
they have to do all this because games
are more expensive to make now back in
the 8 bit and 16bit era when you were
playing you freaking fossil you know you
could make a game with a team of three
people like these days
those AAA games you're bashing on those
take hundreds of people they cost more
to make and they've had to find ways to
make more money that's
true but that brings us back to kind of
a form of planned
obsolescence did they have to be made
bigger and
better they will claim or at least
they're The Defenders of these practices
will claim that the audience and the
players demanded better graphics
demanded more features demanded more
realism did they did they really or is
that what you sold them to justify them
buying a new installment in the game
series because
otherwise maybe we'd still be happy
playing Mortal Kombat 3 Ultimate from
the
mid90s but you don't want us to be happy
with old things you want us to Shell out
again
and if you're basically just selling us
the same game again and that is I'm
sorry it is very much the case
especially in a fighting game genre
where the fundamentals have changed very
little certainly not nearly as much as
some other genres have let forward over
time you want to keep selling us those
on a regular basis well you got to do
something because the core fundamentals
are the same this has actually been a
problem with the video game industry in
general I'd say
at its core of most video game design in
terms of what they're actually doing and
the concepts has stagnated pretty
heavily I'd say
from uh first half of PS3 Xbox 360
generation I think that pretty much any
idea that somebody wanted to do that
like they're doing now could have been
done then it's just a matter of the
technicals like now they do it at a
bigger scale and it's prettier but like
The Core
Concepts they don't need to be flashier
they can work on something that is more
frugal but that would mean we don't have
to buy a new system that would mean we
don't have to buy a new game so that is
sort of the difference with this version
of inchan ification versus planned
obsolescence it's not that the old stuff
is breaking although video games are
notorious for being really bad at
archiving their old games and backwards
compatibility but even setting that
aside it's not that the old stuff
breaking it's that they have to convince
us that they've made something that we
will want instead but even that is
better than some of the other stuff that
happens at the very least while I and
others might argue against how necessary
the continually upgraded realistic
Graphics are like how how much
fundamentally has the gam playay and
core cont Concepts and overall
presentation other than like the
refinement of the realistic Graphics how
much has changed from Mortal Kombat 9 to
the recent released Mortal Kombat 1 cuz
that's not freaking confusing how much
has actually changed not a lot and
actually I could probably go further
back than that but I'm going to go with
that one because that's the one that I
know was very much in the vein of what
has just been locked in for what nether
realm does
now what has changed really just the
visuals
but they have to make the visuals
better because how else are they going
to convince us to keep buying
it because they can't settle to just
sell us a thing and then make a
completely new thing see that's one of
the ways in which things have shifted
over time you remember how I mentioned
like okay so you start by selling a
chair well then you make a new thing you
sell them a table a bed etc you know
what's easier than that if you can do it
sell them the same thing over and over
again not because the old one broke
which was planned obsolescence but
because it's the same thing again but
now with
X now with in the case of video games
prettier Graphics in the case of a lot
of cars Now with uh a touchscreen
dashboard my current car I got in
2019 and I really resent the fact that
it has a touchscreen dashboard for I've
gotten used to it with time but like I
If I had had the
option from that dealership to get one
that didn't have that
console I would have I didn't want it I
didn't need it but they were going to
make me get
it cars are uh another thing that are
kind of notorious in this whole thing
because 30 years ago 40 years ago with a
little mechanic knoow and the right
tools you could maintain your car
yourself you can't now ton of it is
computerized Electronics you need to
have a special diagnostic device that
will hook up and talk to the proprietary
software built into your car it's
actually a bit of a problem for a lot of
local mechanics if you're like me and
you have a mechanic that you currently
trust you want to be able to go to them
they can help you with you know
the raw mechanics of it the engine you
know swap out your uh your air filters
change your oil that kind of thing but
there's a whole swath of stuff that if
it breaks down they can't help because
they can't even diagnose it because to
get something that'll talk to huge parts
of the
car requires proprietary stuff that is
only available for me to take it to the
mechanic at the
dealer and I don't go to the mechanic at
the dealer
if I have any option whatsoever you know
why cuz every single time I've gone to
the mechanic at a
dealer I have been told well you know we
could address this or I could uh direct
you over to the guys over in the sales
department over there and they could
look at trading this in and getting you
a new one with a nice fresh
loan all of this what I've talked about
and so much more It ultimately spawns
from something that I mentioned and I
said we come back to it's not enough to
be profitable you have to be growing in
fact for a while you don't even have to
be profitable as I said most of the
streaming services aren't profitable now
in their cases that's starting to catch
up with them a lot faster than I think
they expected and they have divided the
market up so much that not many of them
are going to be able to make it they're
just going to become money SNS
but I also don't necessarily blame the
uh various Studios and IP holders for
trying because their old methods of
making Revenue off of things like TV and
movies they don't exist
anymore thanks to things like streaming
initially just Netflix but I understand
why these other other businesses wanted
to get in on it because what used to
happen was was however you saw a movie
assuming you saw it by legal means
however you saw a movie you went to the
movie theater they got a cut of the
ticket you rented it from a blockbuster
they got a cut of that rental you bought
a physical copy they got uh part of that
you watched it on TV they got a part of
the ad Revenue however you consumed a
movie they got a piece of it and they
got a piece of it every time you took it
in not every time you watch it if you
like bought the thing you buy it they
only get to sell it to you once but you
buy it they you make money off that you
rent it they make money off that you
seen in the theater they make money off
that and that's for every movie every
time instead with Netflix or any of the
other things
for about the cost of one or two movie
tickets per
month you now have access to
hundreds thousands of movies and
shows but they've only made the one
month subscription off you now
subscriptions can still be very
Insidious especially when implemented
into something that has no bigest
business being a subscription service to
come back to Vehicles real quick BMW
subscription for heated seats and I
forget which car company it was but one
of them is going to have a subscription
service to have the car actually perform
at its best uh ability so introducing a
subscription to something like that
that's just Insidious from the ground up
that's just forcing people to pay extra
for something that they used to just
have and deliberately removing something
you are taking it from them you used to
they used to have it it used to be
standard now you have taken it away so
like subscriptions can't be very
obsidious in
obsidious Insidious but when it comes is
something like a streaming platform you
get one month off of a month
subscription but they can watch so much
stuff and you don't make a perview money
off that you don't make money off it the
way you do on movie tickets the way you
do on movie rentals the way you do on
movie
purchases you just
don't but the thing is those old forms
were either dying or just weren't as
profitable as they used to be n fli was
incredibly
disruptive and Netflix being the one who
got in there first is about the only one
that is in fact profitable again Aster
mountains of debt hey just jumping in
really quick from the editing phase it
looks like from an indie wire article
from earlier this year that Hulu is also
profitable now I don't have as much hard
data on that one as I do on Netflix but
it would make sense since Hulu is the
second oldest of these things and has
had the most time to build up during a
period where there was not nearly as
much competition so yeah that tracks I
get why they
tried because otherwise they were
basically giving up the market
completely to
Netflix and the ways they used to make
money before they were gone but they
launched instead into something
unsustainable and definitely
unsustainable for as many of them as
there are and so now they're being made
worse and charging us more so they're
going to break them they're going to
make them worse and have less and be
more expensive so that they can claw The
Profit back and they will justify that
on the basis of well we Ed to make more
money now like obviously these companies
are making more money year overy year
but it's through a combination of things
a lot of it's Acquisitions and a lot of
it is layoffs but they have their
accounting trickery to make it look like
the company is bigger year-over-year but
in terms of like the actual income
streams on something like entertainment
on something like movies it's not what
it
was and so what they'll do is they will
say well we have to raise the price
we're not pulling in as much from these
things as as we used to even though in
some cases they are at least with some
of these things in the theaters but to
be fair in a lot of cases no you know
they're
not but you built something knowing that
you were going to have to make it worse
later you hooked us in on something
and then charged us more and made it
worse and you do this without ever
touching the salaries of the people who
make tens of millions of dollars per
year at the
top and instead you say well you're just
going to have to pay more I'm afraid
why why we didn't make Bad Business
decisions we haven't made predatory uh
monetization models
you did that we have to pay more for
that and as I said they'll sort of frame
it as a well it's it's it's what we have
to do except it isn't or it wouldn't be
if they didn't have to
grow as opposed to just make a profit
because as I said it is all about growth
now technically if a business is just
profitable does that give returns to
investors because this is all where it
breaks down ultimately the the there are
a ton of problems with capitalism like a
ton but a lot of the worst aspects of it
right now come down to the idea of
investors and what is done to please
investors now investors could just be
making dividends off a profitable
business but the thing is that's not
enough to satisfy the biggest and most
uh aggressive investors anymore because
you make more money off of growth than
you do off of dividends if you are a
stockholder if you are an investor in a
company you make more money by them
getting bigger year over year over year
than you do from them just being
profitable and maintaining you make
something from that but it's not as much
corporations don't just want some of the
money they want all of the money and you
make way more when something is growing
bigger year over year over year now the
streaming services are weird because
they are subdivisions of other companies
for pretty much all of them except like
Netflix with a lot of these companies a
lot of the tech companies Twitter
Facebook any number of
them they weren't profitable some of
them still aren't or they've only been
profitable a couple of
times but they still pulled in heavy
investment because they were
growing were they making money no but
they were growing their user base it was
all about potential how much bigger will
they get what more will they do and so
more money got poured in more investment
got put in stock price rises even though
it's not actually
profitable because being profitable
isn't the point of a business anymore
and I know some people are going to bck
at that well isn't the point of a
corporation to make money yes but that's
not the same as the business model being
profitable because a corporation makes
money by people putting money into it
and investors putting money into it
means it's making
money that does not mean that they have
to be making
profit in the standard sense of their
revenue is higher than their expenses
that's all profit
means but profit isn't enough and profit
isn't what gets you the big bucks what
gets you the big bucks what gets you
launched and adopted
quickly is something that is
deliberately unsustainable it's Hulu
being
free it's Twitter initially launching
with no real advertisements just like
hey come here and do this micr blogging
thing and they got Investments because
they knew if they could get enough
people on it then they could start
having ads then they could start doing
things that would push it then they
could start selling your
data that's a whole other thing and
aspect of this especially when we talk
about the tech
companies all of this has gotten
worse and so many of these companies
launch
unprofitably now like launching un
profitably is standard generally to
launch any business Tech or anything
else you have to put a ton of money in
at the at the start you have to build
whatever it is whether it's a restaurant
to bring the building up to code and get
your kitchen working and staff up or
whether it be a a social media app where
you have to build all the tech
infrastructure and get it coded and make
sure you have the bandwidth to run the
dang thing whatever it is startup costs
are going to be high so there will
always be for any business a per period
where more money has been sunk into it
than it's
generating but the way so much of it has
been built
now is they start out not only having
lost more money than they could
generate but their initial pitch of the
of the business isn't something that is
going to eventually be profitable
because the normal way the way that it
used to work the way that used to be
standard is okay so you have a model
that will that you believe will be
become profitable eventually so after 10
years you'll have covered your initial
startup cost and debt and then it will
be true profit as opposed to revenue
where you just make more than you spent
but you're still in the hole because of
the old stuff again talking about
Netflix and yeah they're profitable in
terms that they have positive Revenue
but they have still mountains of debt
yeah that's the kind of thing I'm
talking about but it used to just be
that okay I want to launch a business
here's my business model this is what I
need to start it up and I believe it
will take me 10 years if I if I am
successful in the way I intend to be the
revenue that I bring in versus the
expenses will have balanced the initial
cost and then it's profit true
profit now it's throw the money in build
something that will never be
profitable but we'll bring in people
we'll get them on board we'll get them
committed we'll get them invested with
their time and their needs if not their
money and then find ways to make money
off them once you have
them in shid ification is a result of
companies and businesses and
models approaching or hitting their
ceiling I've talked about this with
Netflix specifically a couple years ago
they started actually losing
subscribers because eventually that
product was going to hit a ceiling as
many people as were going to want to get
it will have gotten it and so now they
have to Jack out the price now they have
to crack down on password sharing now
they have to find a way to make more
money off the customers they already
have because otherwise they can't
grow and if you can't
grow some investors will leave not all
of them not all of them some will just
stay and be happy with the dividends but
not all of them they'll go oh you're not
growing anymore oh I'm going to pull out
my money and put it into this thing
that's growing and that can if it
happens quickly enough just become a
death spiral
but this is
why the only time that these companies
are honest are usually on investor calls
you'll see them put out their puff
pieces their press releases saying this
that you know oh well we need to do this
or you know it's tough for us to do that
and then stuff will leak out from
investor calls and they're very upfront
with the
investors they will sometimes cook their
numbers in terms of promising to make
more money next year than they did last
year when realistically they know that's
not going to happen and I know I know
that for a fact because I used to work
in sales and I used to work in sales at
a company that was
profitable but it had to grow it had to
grow every year and every year I was
expected as a salesperson for my
forecast to be higher than it was the
previous year even if I could lay out
mathematically why that is not going to
happen with the accounts I have I cannot
make a commitment to make you more money
than I did this past year and certainly
not by as much as you're telling me that
you want it to be they would make me do
it anyway they would make me forecast
anyway and then hold me responsible for
failing to hit the numbers that I told
them I couldn't hit in the first place
but they forced on me because that's
what they needed the numbers to be they
needed everybody in sales to have a
forecast that was higher than the year
before so that they could take that to
well in the case of that company people
who were going to buy it because it
wasn't a big enough company to have
investors in the standard sense but
there was an investment group looking to
buy it and so they wanted to be able to
show them see we made more money this
year and this year and this year and
we're now projecting the end of this
year coming we're going to make even
more even though a bunch of people in
sales were telling them no I can't do
that they would just tell us well give
us a projection for the number we want
and then figure out how to do it they
would make us
lie that's what they do they already
know what number the investors want to
hear and unless things have broken down
so badly that they can't even have the
hope that maybe somehow they'll be able
to pull this out of their ass only then
only then and usually only after it's
happened only after it's taken a
downturn that they probably didn't give
the investors a heads up on because that
would cause them to pull their money in
advance only after they have failed to
meet these things I say with investors
is the only time they're honest that
wasn't really true but it's the closest
they come to
honest because at least after something
goes bad they'll be honest
about what
happened but of course they were
dishonest about their growth potential
in the first place and understand I'm
not trying to single out the company I
used to work for is like I'm blowing the
whistle like no this is what they
do this is what they all
do projections have to be more than the
year
before and then since you've given those
numbers you've promised them to
investors it's now the job of everybody
underneath the executive class to figure
out how to make that
happen the numbers are locked in you
don't get to tell them we think this is
how much this project will make they
tell you this is how much it has to make
and it can't cost more than this figure
it out and you have managers crunching
workers into mandatory overtime and 100
hour work weeks and you have people
getting laid off just to cut the cost so
that the expenses don't exceed what they
were supposed to so that the numbers
balance the way that you already
promised a bunch of investors that
they're going to even though you don't
know how you're possibly going to do
that you say you know how but you don't
really so you raise prices you milk the
customers you screw over the workers you
do everything you can to hit the number
you've already promised to your
investors because they are the only ones
who matter the consumer doesn't matter
the customer doesn't matter the
customer is a cow that you milk for as
much as you can to please the investors
they are the only ones who matter in the
current state of capitalism as it exists
at least when you get to a company of
scale mom and pop stores look you're
still working under the capitalist
system but admittedly these are problems
I'm talking about once you get to a
certain SC I mean once you're at a scale
where you have multiple investors Andor
stockholders shareholders Etc yeah this
is what happens once it scales up once
it gets industrial once it gets big
enough to pull these kinds of investors
this is just what happens
you can't grow every year but you have
to promise you're going
to and so you have to find some way to
do that and if you can't sell them a new
product find a way to make them buy the
old one again promise that has new
features ensure that the old one breaks
start making them pay extra for stuff
that you used to just build in all these
things have to be
done in order to maintain the illusion
of continued growth year-over-year
continued growth is also part of the
reason by the way why a lot of these
Acquisitions
happen Disney bought
Marvel because Marvel had growth
potential Disney bought Lucas film
because Lucas film had growth potential
the Star Wars property in particular was
basically just being used for video
games books books Comics you know which
there's money in that but that's not the
big money the big money is in the movies
so they bought it knowing that they
could grow it bigger by making more
movies they bought
Marvel because they saw what Marvel was
doing and going we we if we own that
then all of their growth becomes our
growth that's why these Acquisitions
happen because at a certain point these
companies they're e being it their main
core business or their various
subsidiaries
eventually they either hit a ceiling or
the inherent unprofitability of the
model catches up with them because maybe
it was never going to work and they
can't keep
growing so you fake growth by buying a
company that does still have growth
potential and growing that and
pretending your entire thing is getting
bigger because because now suddenly
Marvel's growth is on Disney's
ledgers and yeah there you have to have
a certain amount of transparency again
not with the public necessarily but you
have to have a certain amount of
transparency in terms of which divisions
of the company are and aren't
profitable but as I said profitability
isn't
enough other than covid having happened
which was a big hit but like the theme
parks have always been
profitable but they haven't been growing
not that much
but Marvel could grow they could have
you know their Disney output their Pixar
output the theme parks that can be the
base level we're already profitable at
this but we're not growing but then we
grab Marvel we grab lucasfilm now these
can
grow I'm not singling out Disney because
it's the worst offender I mean it might
be I don't know I don't feel like
ranking these things I'm singling out
because it's one that's really easy to
illustrate what I'm talking about
when you can't just make a new product
that people want and sell it you do
whatever you can to pump the
numbers you acquire companies you lay
off your
Workforce you charge more for a product
you spend less to make
it you get people to pay either
continuously or repeatedly for something
they used to pay for only
once you take something you make it
worse you charge
more because you can't just get enough
people to buy it to keep growing you got
to squeeze the ones who are already
there so you again to come back to the
streaming services where we started you
strip out content that's stuff you now
don't have to pay residuals on don't
have to pay the storage space to host
the
media and you charge more you've saved
money and you're pulling in more and you
do it by screwing over the people that
supposedly are meant to
matter customers always right nah
customer always an at least
that's how they view US is there a
solution at this point I don't
know
like
regulation I don't know if that will fix
what's already happened cuz the purpose
of regulation of Industries like this of
antitrust regulation and uh and all
these sorts of things the intent of that
was to stop the current situation from
happening but the situation has already
happened and I don't know if if
regulation can roll us back to an
earlier point and I don't know how far
back you'd have to roll to have it not
still be a nightmare like 50 years
probably but even then we're still stuck
in the same system with the same
incentives and the same ability to be
broken in the exact same ways it already
has been the inhi ification of our apps
websites entertainment Etc is just an
embodiment of late stage capitalism it
is an encapsulation of what's wrong with
the whole damn system and I didn't
necessarily come into this intending to
do a direct and pointed indictment of
capitalism as a whole
but never forget that capitalism is
exploitative by
nature the only way a business can be
profitable is if they pay the people who
make it less than they will sell it for
so the value that
labor brings to create the product will
always be underpaid
or the customer will always be
overcharged one of those two things has
to be the case because if you paid
people what their labor was worth then
you would just break
even because their labor creates the
product and gave it value you now have
to sell it for more than you paid them
so if we take that price that you sold
it at as what the thing is worth you've
paid them less than the value of their
labor because that's the only way you
can make a
profit
or you jack up the price beyond what is
reasonable beyond what you should be
charging and you screw over the customer
or increasingly you do both you underpay
your workers you overcharge your
customers but while it has gotten
worse that core nugget of exploitation
is built into the system it is the
nature of
capitalism it
requires that workers be paid less than
the value their labor
brings that is literally the nature of
the system
it is exploitative by nature the degree
of that exploitation has
exploded in the last 40
years but it's always been there it's an
exploitative system by
Design
yay did I just depress the heck out of
all of you I'm
sorry kind of had to get all the stuff
off my chest clearly given how long I've
just gone off
but yeah enough people said that they
wanted to hear me go off about it that I
was like okay I guess I'm dumping
everything into this again I didn't
necessarily mean to but wel come to my
brain these connections exist in my head
it's really hard for me to talk about
just the one thing without pulling in
and this illustrates that and this is
because of that and that and here's this
thing I know
I try and restrain my brain a little bit
more most times I just kind of let it do
its thing this time so welcome to a
slightly less filtered version of my
head and thank you for watching if you
are this far in my goodness bless
you but whatever your thoughts are on
any of this including if you disagree
with me which like you're entitled to do
I obviously have a very strong belief in
my convictions and my point of view but
like if you can do it without calling me
vicious names or being transphobic at me
for no reason given that I didn't bring
up trans issues if you can offer
criticism or critique for what I've said
without doing those things I'm open to
that but whatever your thoughts might be
drop them down in the comments and let's
talk about it patreon is how I am able
to continue to exist in the capitalist
hellscape in which we are all trapped
any amount is of great assistance it is
why I'm able to actually talk about
things like this
CU goodness knows what the YouTube
algorithm is going to do to this I have
no
clue it likes me when I talk about stuff
that can be classified as drama which I
don't like talking about but it plays
well this probably won't but regardless
patreon is what ensures that I a I'm
able to keep coming back and keep
talking to you folks about this
geekiness fun stuff sometimes even
whatever it might be but if you can't
help me out that way that's okay there's
links to other stuff I do down in the
description the like share
subscribe those help don't worry too
much about it
though what I really want you to
remember is though we may all be trapped
in this
system that doesn't change the fact that
you are
beautiful you are valid
and you are
loved you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is a
[Music]
Jour time for me to thank my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
Lula goddess ala Oliver be to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
goes of the gazarian solitary pictures
old rck bugden geek filter Melinda
Walters toku BL huian Jen aun K 808
Becky Sparks jobi likes the poodle Robin
Powell t love Tracy scrapit angry caspel
Dave Hall quite bearish rosin Bennett po
baraba
jagal I'm sorry for whatever Butchery I
did to that and Mirra G I know I've kind
of done like funky stuff saying them the
last few times I had this whole idea
where I was going to like sing them to
the tune of Carol the Bells but then I
realized it's going to like Clash with
my outro music and I didn't really want
to rework that or just cut the outro
music out all together that felt weird
so I just I just didn't just didn't I
just didn't do a thing this time but now
I've told you that I didn't do a thing
so I've made a thing about there being
no okay thanks for sticking around
bye